much like their mythical namesakes
vampire bats must feast on fresh blood
every two to three days or die of
starvation they seek out warm-blooded
mammals thriving off domestic livestock
living in the tropical regions of South
and Central America most victims never
feel a thing and the bite itself is
superficial but increasingly bats are
targeting humans and the encounters are
turning deadly the bats are blamed for
rabies outbreaks in Peru a National
Geographic grantee Daniel Stryker is
researching the environmental causes and
extent of the disease vampire bats are
kind of the perfect storm of different
ecological characteristics on the 110
these bats are feeding on larger mammals
which are susceptible to rabies and in
order to feed on these animals to drink
their blood they have to bite inviting
is also the main route of transmission
of rabies virus Stryker is surveying
vampire bats from the Amazon rainforest
to the farms along the valleys of the
Andes Mountains vampire bats are native
to Peru but 500 years ago settlers
imported an ideal food source cattle and
as the number of livestock increases and
spreads across the country so too is the
population of vampire bats today large
colonies thrive near areas devoted to
ranching yet despite the burgeoning bat
population it's rare for people living
in these agricultural areas to become
infected with rabies
rabies is a frightening and deadly
disease the classic form of the disease
turns even docile creatures into
aggressors that foam at the mouth but
the strain found in vampire bats is
different it's known as paralytic or
dumb rabies causing disorientation
muscle weakness and eventually death
to learn more he must turn the tables
this time it's a human taking blood from
a vampire working at the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention or the
CDC in Atlanta
Streicher adds a lab strain of the
rabies virus to blood samples he
collected from vampire bats in Peru
after an incubation period the test
results will show which bats had been
exposed to the rabies under the
microscope fluorescent green dye
indicates no antibodies present meaning
the bat was free of disease but if the
results come back clear the bat has
antibodies and strike her nose the bat
was exposed to rabies in the recent past
this is an important test for us because
it allows us to first determine whether
the virus is present or absent in a bat
population and finally we can ask some
questions at the population level
specifically asking things like as you
have more livestock in a given area do
you see a heart rapport shamaa bats that
that have been exposed to this virus
preliminary results indicate that
vampire bats from agricultural areas may
actually have a higher rate of infection
than new bats from other parts of the
country so why then to so few people who
live near cattle ranches fall ill with
rabies if there are so many bats around
infected with the disease Stryker
believes that the livestock act as a
buffer bats prefer passive herds to
people reducing the attacks on people
but as vampire bat populations increase
and more lifestyle become infected this
could pose a greater rabies threat to
people in the future the same theory may
explain why human rabies is more common
in Peru's Amazon rainforest here
developments such as logging mining and
road construction is wiped out vast
tracts of habitat and reduced wildlife
populations and since there's not much
livestock in this area the bats turn to
another food source humans there may be
fewer infected bats but they bite people
more frequently could this be why the
disease is far more common here than in
the Andes there's much more to learn
about how widespread rabies is among the
countries bat population what we don't
know is how this disease is persisting
in the vampire bats and we and as a
correlative that we don't know where it
is in vampire bats so again much more
widespread potentially it's all it's
always present than these populations
[Music]
striker will continue to collect data
hoping his research will eventually help
predict where people will need to be
vaccinated the more he learns about this
frightening disease the better the
chance we may someday be able to control
it sponsored by National Geographic
mission programs taking science and
exploration into the new millennium